here's the big story from cnn merrick
garland does not rule out charging trump
and others in january 6th probe and i'm
just going to say it i want to bury the
lead i think the story is a big hoax i
think it's a big nothing burger and how
do you say nothing while still riling up
democrats this is exactly how you do it
you go to someone when there's no
criminal investigation and no charges
and say would you charge him if you
found a crime well we're not going to
rule out anything there's no there's no
look let me show you the story from
washington post
justice department investigating trump's
actions
in january 6 criminal probe and we
addressed it a little bit last night but
i'm like i'm seeing all this news pop up
i got to just say it right now let me
put it this way
lauren southern is drinking my very
expensive whiskey let's say we did not
know who was doing it
and so i decide i know ian doesn't drink
it but i'm going to investigate what he
was doing this night not that i'm
accusing him of stealing my whiskey but
something he did may lead me to
information about what happened to my
whiskey this is how i know
in my is why i would say in my opinion
this story from the washington post is
total bs
investigating trump's actions you can't
criminally charge someone's actions
it may be that they're fishing
it may be there's someone else under
criminal investigation and they're
looking at what trump said to him to see
if this person committed a crime but if
i'll just tell you right now if trump
really was under criminal investigation
they would be screaming it to the high
heavens right what but can we get down
to the bottom of what this is all about
it's they're terrified of him the
january 6 committee hearings this
ridiculousness
they're terrified of them running again
they do view him as an existential
threat to the system to the
administrative state that's what this is
what all of this is about it has nothing
to do with anything because there is no
validity to it he said he was going to
fire everybody but exactly
how do you actually get trump to not run
again in 2024 and ostracize his
political supporters from the body
politic that's what they're trying to do
and i think it's great he's he's taking
it head on i mean he came back to dc the
other day and spoke in dc and people
called it controversial
i have no idea like why is it
controversial that a former president
came and spoke in dc oh because of
january 6 the show trial
which has nothing to do with anything
about the facts that happened on january
6th the big story was that he uh called
for the death penalty for drug dealers
like duterte very cool
it was like china doesn't have a drug
problem i think the january 6 committee
hearings have actually helped him
on the path to running again for
re-election have actually strengthened
him i agree and i'll tell you in a
re-election bid and i i i agree with you
and i think it's because the the the
show trial has been so absurd yeah that
it's actually weakened their case
against trump i think the less people
knew about it many of them were probably
like wow something bad happened then you
get this show trial and there's many
inconsistencies and like when dr
hutchinson oh i know does all hearsay
donald trump jumped and grabbed some
guy's neck people are probably like what
listen listen megatz you just don't
understand we're going to get him this
time
we're going to get him
i wonder if there are actually people
out there though like democrats that are
just sitting there watching the view
every day watching rachel maddow that
are like oh my gosh every time they get
right up and they're still falling for
it like i think there's two of those
people
yes they have to be out there yeah 25 30
i think actually so embarrassing it is
embarrassing really embarrassing but i
think a lot of the normies are looking
at this like you said to him and going
there's no they're there you're bringing
in cassidy hutchinson all these people
it's it's hearsay and then they bring in
pat cipolloni who basically undermines
the secret service agents undermine it's
the more they they more that they're
actually advertising and broadcast and
bring bringing the abc producer to
showtime
people going there's what are what are
we talking about right here there's no
opposing uh they can't get to there's no
cross
examination only paul this year uh
amazing meme of chris pratt
the top one is chris pratt with a
shocked happy face saying the first time
a democrat hears the mainstream media
say they have information that will
totally bring down trump right and then
underneath it it says the 4 689th time a
democrat hears the msm say they have
information that will totally bring down
trump and it's the same happy face no
matter how many times they claim it
never gets old
i remember when uh you know it was like
march of 2021 and these like deep
conspiracy people were like trump's
gonna get reinstated as president it's
coming and i'm just like me and every
other same person was like guys that's
never going to happen it's kind of like
when people watch the same movie over
and over again or listen to the same
song and you they they like it more
as they hear it more
like the 30th time you hear a song it's
like oh now it's even more part of my
soul so like is that what's happening
with the media telling them trump is bad
is it like getting more they actually
like it even more the next time they
hear it
i think they're hop all hopped up on
hopium and there's no coming down
they're desperate for it to be true they
are absolutely desperate for it what
would it accomplish if it were true what
would it accomplish for instance
positively for the country and for
people what do you think would happen
absolutely nothing no i mean it would
only it would only accelerate the rapid
separation in parts of our society and
culture
if you were to weaponize this is the
other thing too
that i love that trump's standing up to
this
somebody's actually standing up to the
weaponization of the law
which is trump which if we're not very
careful that's how that's how republics
which technically we still are end when
you weaponize the law against political
opponents that's exactly what democrats
are trying to do here see that's the
problem they're weaponizing it against
opponents we just need to weaponize it
against all politicians
i don't disagree at all
i'm an equal opportunist yeah there's
plenty of people all in jail i'm okay
what's this like i don't know trading
stocks with your insider information
like let's just but you're just talking
about accountability for accountability
these people who never face it ever yes
yeah
yeah never once
at some point i mean at some point equal
application of the law is foundational
to our constitutional republic we have a
bifurcated system in which we are now
weaponizing the law against political
opponents
because reasons and that's what it's
because reasons this is what the media
does take a look at this from the
independent donald trump being
investigated by doj in january 6
criminal probe report says no it doesn't
say that at all this is how they launder
the information there's no story the
washington post has no story the the
story is investigators asked some people
about what trump was doing or something
like that and it's like okay does that
mean trump is being investigated
criminally no it doesn't he maybe he
will be you know there's a possibility
that
they're trying to tread lightly and
going after him to not you know shock
the system and cause riots if they came
out and just announced they were doing
it people might get mad so maybe they're
trying to slow roll it i think the
reality is they got nothing and so
they're trying to make it seem like
something is happening and that's why
they put the story out yeah well they
need a story i was just reading a daily
beast article the other day that said
the pope has come to apologize for mass
graves in canada um of course there's no
mass graves and the pope didn't come
with those intentions but if you scroll
down and you click the hyperlinks in the
article that's referencing it all links
to other daily beast articles that are
completely irrelevant to the article
itself and it's like
the way they source this stuff the way
that they write these articles just
desperation for something to latch on to
that's
you know hyper exaggerated for the
audience it's it's tearing our
civilization apart
it's tearing us apart corporate
propagandists i refused to call them
mainstream media on that level corporate
propagandists who are not there to
actually get to the truth of something
but to amplify the message
the narrative of the system
yeah i think for a lot of these people
it's emergent you know some people
believe that at these news organizations
there is a you know hierarchy of a cabal
telling them you must claim trump did
this or that in reality it's just people
trying to maximize what is was
acceptable within their sphere to get
more clicks so what happens is the
washington post publishes a story
exclusive trump's actions being
investigated means nothing someone at
the independent is like
i want to get clicks uh trump's being
investigated because i've heard people
say that to me they said tim this means
trump is being investigated i'm like no
it doesn't in fact even maggie haberman
at the new york times wrote this does
not mean trump is under investigation
but they they try and do it
this is how
these these you know facebook moms
and msnbc moms and dads get their minds
warped
that their so this independent story is
going to get laundered again and you're
going to get some pundit on msnbc saying
and and now the doj is investigating
trump in a criminal probe i mean this
guy's going down the walls are closing
in yeah they're going to believe it and
reference the independent and everything
because they all just yeah they they
reference each other's opinion pieces
eternally until it's an echo chamber
amplified the message no it it is but i
i think you're on to some obviously they
feed off each other at the same time
they all come from
i call them indoctrination centers of
higher learning they've all come out of
the same system so they all think the
same way they all view the world same
way and they just end up in different
parts and they amplify each other but
they're all coming from the same
cult world trilateral i don't know who's
doing what's this liberal international
economy is like it's there's the liberal
international economy the us britain
australia and then there's the chinese
international economy which is like
china russia india and the thing about
it is like yeah there's like they've
mobilized the media abc cnn to work for
the liberal international economy but i
think if trump was president and was
nationalizing industry that it would
actually be very good for the liberal
international i don't understand why
it's like a personal vendetta between
him and hillary clinton when he's like
you should be in jail he started the
whole weaponizing
politics like he threatened to put her
in jail on his campaign against her they
they
i've talked about it ad nauseum with the
cutter turkey pipeline donald trump
getting our troops out of the middle
east him saying i don't care about these
oil pipelines that was bad for the
liberal international economy they want
a new world they want a new world
economy they do want a new world order
they've said it many times and i maybe
trump's just not they think he's not the
guy to trust
trump doesn't want that well there's got
to be some sort of world order otherwise
it's world chaos it's the boomer world
order okay how old is hillary clinton
does anyone know she's like seven seven
okay do you know what the average age of
our politicians or uh prime
prime ministers
presidents in the us was
for the past like since the dawn of time
it's usually been around 50. it's only
been the last few presidents that have
been like 70s 80s like getting up there
and it's because the boomers just will
not let go
they won't let go of the industries they
won't let go of the political positions
and then you've got a lot of young
people millennials gen x all these
younger generations that see no upward
mobility in anywhere in politics no
ability to influence the system
and the boomers will never give it to
them so like as much as i like trump as
a politician it's just you know
it's all of this same generation
refusing to let go of civilization and
then every other generation has become
apathetic i will i will say though i
will say though um
the boomers aren't all bad no there are
some bad courses and they they've
latched on to power
what i think the problem is that
millennials are probably going to be
worse now i know i can hear the gen xers
already screaming saying you're cutting
us out and i'm like no no it's because
actually gen x's i don't think are all
that bad they're not the ones who are
squeezing the reins of power and
corrupting the system they're these are
you know people who are coming in and
you know doing a moderately good job and
millennials are nuts so when the boomers
finally relinquish power and it floods
down to gen x and millennials those
insane millennials are gonna just really
screw things up you gotta they're
setting an example these these gen
whatever they are the old people in
power right now that to the millennials
if they do get empowered they're gonna
wanna be there for 50 years because like
that's what happened before but they
should be in and out people should be in
and out yeah this was never intended
well we have today it was never intended
to be 40 50 years in the senate whatever
it is you know it it was meant to be
much i mean the average term for a
congressman i think was what two
until turn of the century turn of the
20th century i mean there were a lot of
things that have changed dramatically
over the last hundred years you were
never meant to be there for as long as
they're out they've been yeah but no i a
little bit on lauren
i totally agree
it's time for new leadership we've got
great leadership coming up ron desantis
yes josh hawley
i'm hoping jd vance blake masters
you're going to see a lot of 30 and 40
somethings who are going to be leaders
in the senate
you know my my perfect world is trump
2024 and ron desantis you know 20 28 20
32 santa's 24 what do you think
uh i i actually love that idea if they
could work it out i think trump would
have to go have his uh in new jersey and
and desantis out of florida but yeah
i've heard i've you know i've heard that
but i don't i i read that wasn't true
that really the president the vice
president yeah that's a relic of the
1800s okay but that could be regardless
i think it'd be a great ticket trump is
in new jersey right now right i think it
would be a great ticket
and i think if you had trump desantis
you set him up perfectly for a run in
2020 he'd only be
49 something like that yeah we need to
make room for these new people there's
some really good new yeah i mean i
totally agree i want i want one last run
with trump
yeah
i'd like to see and i want him to
announce before the midterms by the way
i wrote a piece on that today why do you
think he should announce before because
i think he's an asset
everybody wants to say he's not an asset
i think he's an asset he reminds people
of what was not what is oh yeah what did
we have we had 1.7 inflation we had 3.5
percent unemployment two dollar gas two
dollar gas we had a booming economy
domestic energy net exporter
at all these great things that jobs
brought the auto industry back to
manufacturing jobs all of these great
things he was taking it to china he was
he was emphasizing even though he wasn't
as successful in the southern border as
he could have been he was still getting
there
he can remind people of what was hey you
want this back get all these people in
and we can get us back on the course of
taking back the country in 2024. i think
he announces tuesday after labor day you
know when he talked about building a
wall and instead of he phrased it as
like we got to keep out and then the
media was like mexicans like you didn't
but
what he kind of meant was like the
cartels and child trafficking human but
he didn't emphasize that enough but did
you see the really funny article today
about in the la times about mexico city
that are deeply resentful of all the
californians in america yes we don't
want them here they're changing our
culture we want them to go home
yes you didn't see this
it was amazing
i'm like i tell you what i'll make a
deal with you mexico we'll take back all
the americans you take back all the
mexicans we're good now you see what
it's like yeah no it was it was actually
quite hilarious when they
admitted we don't like having them here
because they're changing our culture
they're changing everything about this
city mexico city
we don't want them here yeah thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you